hey schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute
live 30 jahre sind diese bilder her und
sie machen aber heute immer noch genauso
fassungslos in rostock lichtenhagen
stecken rechtsextreme ein wohnheim für
vietnamesische familien genannt das
sonnenblumenhaus und die zentrale
aufnahmestelle für asylbewerber in brand
sie schmeißen steine
molotow-cocktails flaschen und das
teilweise ungehindert von der polizei
eine richtige aufarbeitung der anschläge
die gibt es bis heute nicht und heute
kann sich diese furchtbaren anschläge
zum dreißigsten mal das ist unser thema
zum einen das gedenken der
bundespräsident wird in wenigen minuten
auch dazu eine rede halten wir wollen da
auch live hin schalten aber bei uns vor
allem heute auch die frage was hat sich
seitdem getan rechter hass wie schlimm
ist es heute wir werden dazu sprechen
mit der autorin politologin emilia rohr
hinter mir im bild im zweiten teil
dieser sendung nach der rede des
bundespräsidenten und haben jetzt am
anfang der sendung einen zeitzeugen
nenne ich es mal ist es termindruck er
war damals ein kind und er lebte mit
seiner familie im sonnenblumenhaus und
wir können gleich mit ihm sprechen
stellt gerne eure fragen schreibt
anmerkungen direkt in den stream oder
per mail ganz wer das möchte und ein
bericht was damals genau passiert ist
dann wollen wir uns jetzt am anfang
gemeinsam anschauen ein bericht von
ralph goldmann
es ist der 25 august 1992 rostock
lichtenhagen
mecklenburger allee am sogenannten
sonnenblumenhaus hier lebend vor allem
vietnamesen schon tage zuvor hatten sich
hier rechtsextreme versammelt am abend
gerät die lage außer kontrolle
die menge skandiert ausländerfeindliche
parolen es fliegen steine die polizei
zieht sich zurück drinnen eingeschlossen
mehr als 100 vietnamesen und ein
kamerateam des zdf
wir können das gar nicht betreiben
warum mit solche ausmaße gegen ausländer
gegen halb zehn klettern die ersten auf
die balkone zünden gardinen an
molotow-cocktails fliegen in das
erdgeschoss der rechte mob steckt das
haus in brand drinnen breitet sich
beißender qualm aus die eingeschlossenen
flüchten in die oberen stockwerke
sie helfen einander bauen barrikaden auf
um sich zu schützen der
ausländerbeauftragte wolfgang richter
ist ebenfalls im haus die quoten sind
unten durch die tür eingedrungen das
habe schon telefoniert
die polizei ist weg zurück in klein hat
es nicht begriffen
sie haben es nicht will christoffers
hervor wie die polizei in rostock 110
ist bis 26 mal und bis jetzt probiere
selbst bis 1 verloren
diese ausländer hier zwei nächte lang
gespürt haben und wir bekommen sie jetzt
hautnah zu spüren
magda die rechten werfen währenddessen
immer mehr brandbomben gegen das haus
die flammen breiten sich immer weiter
aus den vietnamesen gelingt es
schließlich eine tür in der oberen etage
aufzubrechen und über das dach ins freie
zu gelangen sie können sich mit einigen
bewohnern und den journalisten über ein
anderes treppenhaus retten alleine
gelassen von feuerwehr und polizei und
von denen die dabei stehen und klatschen
es ist doch wahnsinn
14-jährige stehen unsere zukunft und
zukunft die da drauf steht warum machen
sie sind maximal 50 skinhead oder
vorschuss richtige aber der rest noch
mitläufer vier tage dauert die
ausschreitungen wie durch ein wunder
wird niemand ernsthaft verletzt es ist
ein dunkles kapitel deutscher geschichte
das auch 30 jahre später immer noch
nachwirkt
live in rostock lichtenhagen ist mir
jetzt termindruck zugeschaltet der als
kind mit seinen eltern im
sonnenblumenhaus lebte hallo herr termin
unter der termin sie waren ein kleines
kind aber an was erinnern sie sich vor
allem auch an was für eine stimmung
damals in rostock lichtenhagen
genau ich war noch keine vier jahre alt
in dem august und wir haben eine
mecklenburger allee 19 gewohnt
eigentlich ja mein ganzes leben nach
meine eltern seit 82
und ich erinnere mich nur noch an gleich
an die massen an menschen die da gegrölt
haben natürlich ausländer raus
deutschland den deutschen und ich glaube
als kleines kind hat man das nicht
wirklich verstanden man hat diese angst
gespürt aber
ich habe zu meiner eltern immer gesagt
also ich bin doch kein ausländer so mein
opa als ausländer aber ich nicht und
ja jeden tag daran vorbei zu laufen war
schon irgendwie
ich bin überrascht dass halt nichts
passiert ist nichts schlimmeres ich bin
jeden morgen mit meinem opa zum
kindergarten in lichtenhagen und
nachmittags dann wieder zurück und dann
musste man an den menschenmassen vorbei
laufen sie haben auch das 2001 noch mit
ihrer familie im sonnenblumenhaus gelebt
hat sich denn nach diesen anschlägen
überhaupt etwas geändert an dieser
feindlichen rassistischen stimmung wie
haben sie die jahre danach erlebt
grundsätzlich muss ich sagen dass ich in
lichtenhagen eine wunderschöne kindheit
verlebt habe also ich bin ja selbst noch
also das ganze
grundschulalter war ich noch in
lichtenhagen
und erst durch die arbeit meine eltern
also weil sie noch im restaurant
aufgemacht haben sind wir dann 2001 also
fast zehn jahre später
weggezogen aber
lichtenhagen war für uns immer das zu
hause und ich glaube deswegen haben wir
ja auch noch so viele jahre drin ja
gelebt im sonnenblumenhaus
ob sie sich jetzt groß was verändert hat
also
ich empfinde die 90er jahre schon als so
diese typischen skinhead jahre
man die rechte gesinnung den leuten
sofort ansehen konnte springerstiefel
bomberjacke lägen vor jetzt noch
baseballschläger so wirklich das
klischee und
anfang 2000 ich bin mir nicht sicher ob
es sich wirklich verändert hat in der
gesellschaft aber man hat die leute
nicht mehr angesehen jetzt auch heute
ist es eher dieser alltagsrassismus und
man bekommt es dann eher in bestimmten
situationen alltagssituationen
vielleicht zu spülen was bekommen sie da
konkret zu spüren wollen sie darüber
sprechen
schwierig also klar bekommt man auf der
straße manchmal irgendwelche dummen
bemerkungen
ich weiß nicht ob ich dir also
schlitzaugen
fidschis das sind halt so die normalen
wörter die man schon als alltäglich
empfinden kann auch wenn das eher
traurig ist sie sind ja heute selbst
vater meine ich sie haben selbst kinder
erziehen sie die heute zu einer gewissen
vorsicht gegenüber rassistischer
äußerungen oder sind sie da jetzt nicht
beeinflusst unbedingt mehr von diesen
schrecklichen ereignissen auch von vor
30 jahren
ich meine besonders die vietnamesische
community hier in rostock oder ob
in ganz deutschland hat es geschafft da
ihr leben weiter zu leben und
trotzdem mache ich mir natürlich jetzt
auch gedanken weil mein sohn ist jetzt
zwei jahre also noch nicht ganz so alt
wie ich damals zu der zeit in
lichtenhagen
arbeit natürlich überlegt man sich wie
wie erziehe ich meine kinder so dass sie
ja darauf vorbereitet sind dass es halt
nicht nur die lieben freunde sind die im
kindergarten sind sondern halt auch
vielleicht
menschen mit rassistischen gedankengut
die haben den mangel begegnen kann es
gibt eine frage direkt aus dem stream
bei youtube ansehen und zwar hat sich
jemals einer der täter damit sind also
die menschen damals vor 30 jahren die
das haus angegriffen haben in dem sie
gelebt haben hat sich jemals einer
dieser täter persönlich entschuldigt bei
ihnen oder anderen
ja also
man muss ja auch sagen dass damals die
massen ja es waren viele neonazis und
rechtsradikale dabei aber es waren halt
auch ganz normale menschen aus der
nachbarschaft die
applaudiert haben geklatscht das hat am
ende so eine
eigendynamik angenommen
dass wirklich
die tausenden von menschen die da unten
standen das waren ja nicht alles
neonazis und
das ist eine sehr interessante frage
weil meine eltern hatten auf der anderen
seite von der brücke einen kleinen
imbiss wagen
und auch selbst für den ausschreitungen
haben sie halt weiter gearbeitet
und die täter haben halt auch beim hin
eltern ja gegessen getrunken und
haben natürlich auch gesagt das tut uns
leid was wir da machen aber wir müssen
ein
politisches statement setzen weil wir
nicht gehört werden
und auch hier mal so wenn man die leute
aus dem viertel jahre lang danach
getroffen hat einige haben sich
entschuldigt
vielen dank termindruck dass sie ihre
erlebnisse von damals mit uns geteilt
haben ich sehe gerade dass nun gleich
der bundespräsident sprechen wird wie
man könnte mit sicherheit noch viel viel
länger mit ihnen sprechen und vielen
dank dass wir das gehört haben eben
gerade und wir schalten jetzt aber auch
oder sie sind sie sind noch bei uns das
finde ich super weil ich habe gerade
gesehen ist verzögert sich noch ein
bisschen und ich wollte sie auch noch
fragen also heute zur aktuellen lage
wäre natürlich auch die frage wie was
sie sich wünschen für die zukunft was
muss sich ändern natürlich in rostock
lichtenhagen in deutschland dass sie
ihre kinder da natürlich auch andere
erfahrungen machen als das natürlich der
vergangenheit der fall war
rostock hat sich in den letzten jahren
extrem zum positiven verändert weshalb
dieses ist wirklich
bild von lichten hang 92 allgemein mit
rassismus gleichzusetzen wäre auch nicht
fair weil es denke ich mal auch in ganz
deutschland ja ist es ja auch passiert
solche ausschreitungen
und
das ist eine schwierige frage wie kann
man es verändern also was sitzen so
viele experten und politiker
entscheidungsträger daran die es in den
letzten jahrzehnten nicht ändern konnten
und ich glaube nur wir als menschen
können schritt für schritt aufeinander
zugehen empathie
verständnis
um wirklich miteinander leben zu können
rechtsgesinnten wird man nicht einfach
sagen können du dann nicht denkweise ist
nicht in ordnung also
ja es ist eine ganz schwierige thematik
auch und vor allem natürlich hier im
vollkommen recht eine frage und
antworten die weiße menschen natürlich
in diesem land geben müssen den menschen
die von rassismus betroffen sind und
deswegen das ist natürlich eine frage
die sich hier alle in dieser
gesellschaft die weiß sind auch stellen
müssen ich möchte kommentare kurz aus
unserer community dazu noch aufgreifen
zu den ereignissen von vor 30 jahren
rostock lichtenhagen nina nina schreibt
dazu bei facebook das hat mich zutiefst
erschüttert und ich muss leider sehr
schmerzlich feststellen dass nichts
daraus gelernt wurde schreibt sie
politisch und gesellschaftlich als kann
jeden tag irgendwo genauso wieder
geschehen das bricht mir das herz ist
tut mir in der seele weh beschreibt nina
und oben schreibt bei youtube vielleicht
aus eigener erfahrung
subtiler hass er versteckt und manchmal
sind es nur die blicke das macht
unglaublich wütend da ging es noch mal
um das thema alltagsrassismus nämlich an
das war ja auch etwas was sie
angesprochen haben was ich gerne noch
von ihnen auch wissen möchte solche
ereignisse auch wenn sie die natürlich
nur als kind erlebt haben aber ihre l
als erwachsene menschen die eben in
dieses land gekommen sind lassen einen
solche ereignisse jemals wieder los ich
kann es mir kaum vorstellen
es kommt natürlich auf die
persönlichkeit darauf an aber
die menschen mit denen ich gesprochen
habe also auch in der familie
ich kann jetzt nur für mich dann
antworten nein ist lässt eigentlich los
weil genau das ist es diese blicke die
man spielt ohne irgendwie komplexe
darüber zu haben aber man spürt schon
dass man wegen seines aussehens halt so
angeguckt wird ohne überhaupt schon
miteinander kommuniziert zu haben das
sind vorurteile und das gilt es
diese vorurteile zu brechen
ich habe noch einen interessanten
kommentar gerade gelesen den ich vor
lesen möchte und zwar weil facebook
hatte ich den gesehen das problem waren
nicht nur neonazis die feuer gelegt
haben sondern auch die umstehenden die
geholt und beifall geklatscht haben
ebenso wie die verharmloser und
claqueure unter den kommandierenden hier
schreibt der schreibt der user sollten
wir nicht schon viel weiter sein ja sie
haben es angesprochen es gab also auch
umstehende die zugeschaut haben das ist
also ja auch ein kontakt den mann weiter
natürlich tagtäglich hatte in der stadt
das haben sie auch angesprochen ich
danke ihnen ganz herzlich dass sie ihre
erlebnisse mit uns geteilt haben
termindruck war das und wir schalten nun
rüber und hören der rede des
bundespräsidenten präsidenten zu vielen
dank herr termin
danke danke
und es dauert noch eine weile höre ich
gerade ist dauert noch eine weile bis
der bundespräsident spricht aber wir
haben natürlich auch heute unsere
reporterinnen und reporter unterwegs
gehabt an diesem tag 30 jahre nach
rostock lichtenhagen und der
bundespräsident der also gleich sprechen
wird war heute auch den ganzen tag über
schon in der region unterwegs und dazu
haben wir auch einen beitrag von susanne
seidel den wir jetzt gemeinsam anschauen
können
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
ist nach rostock lichtenhagen gekommen
um am symbolträchtigen sonnenblumenhaus
an die fremdenfeindlichen
ausschreitungen von 1992 zu erinnern
es ist ein mahnmal und es erinnert
unserer
tage der schande in unserem land und das
bedeutet dass wir uns erinnern müssen ja
aber vor allen dingen dass demokratie
wehrhaft sein müssen
und die bürgerinnen und bürger einer
demokratie wachsam august 92 vor der
damaligen erstaufnahmeeinrichtung
campieren mitten im wohngebiet
wochenlang geflüchtete weil das heim
überfüllt ist ein wütender mob aus
anwohnern und zum teil zu gereicht
neonazis aus ganz deutschland greift die
erstaufnahmeeinrichtung und das
nebenliegende wohnheim von vietnamesen
an unter beifall von zuschauern die
polizeikräfte sind angesichts der gewalt
überfordert auch heute gibt es noch
rassismus in rostock doch inzwischen
machen sich mehr als 60 aktionsbündnisse
gegen rechte strukturen stark
das muss man sich jeden tag wieder neu
erarbeiten die zivilgesellschaft die
vereine die institution und die
politisch verantwortlichen gemeinsam
jeden tag neu erarbeiten sowie der
internationale fußball club rostock mit
seinem engagement oder der verein sie an
von der die menschen zusammenführen will
nicht nebeneinander leben sondern
miteinander und zusammennehmen
friedliche miteinander zusammenleben sie
wollen auch nach der gedenkwoche weiter
zusammen singen
[Musik]
und da der bundespräsident noch auf sich
warten lässt ist termindruck so
freundlich noch ein bisschen länger mit
uns zu sprechen ich möchte aber auf eine
sache ganz wichtig jetzt noch mal kurz
hinweisen dass hass und hetze in unseren
kommentarspalten ausdrücklich nicht
erwünscht ist und auch entfernt wird und
deswegen möchten wir hier konstruktiv
diskutieren und ausschließlich
konstruktiv diskutieren deswegen dazu
noch mal ganz klar ein statement hass
und hetze hat in unserer kommentarspalte
ganz sicher nichts verloren in ordnung
ich freue mich sehr also is a mean druck
dass sie für uns in rostock lichtenhagen
noch vor ort sind sie vielleicht könnten
sie uns noch mal beschreiben wie das
damals war sie hatten ja die möglichkeit
die schrecklichen echte nicht in der
wohnung zu verbringen sie sind bei
freunden untergekommen ist das richtig
ja es waren ja ungefähr ich bin mir
jetzt nicht genau sicher 4 5 nächte
wirklich die massen da standen das hat
sich ja jeden tag immer ein bisschen
mehr aufgebaut diese spannung die sich
dann an dem 26 korrigieren sie mich wenn
ich falsch liege mit den fakten oder dem
datum
und wir haben im fünften stock gewohnt
jeden tag immer noch kindergartenarbeit
alles ganz normal abends wieder zurück
gekommen
und am letzten abend da diese bilder die
man kennt wo wirklich unsere landsleute
bis aufs dach steigen mussten um in die
anderen hausnummern zu fliegen an dem
abend wurden wir von unseren deutschen
freund ist eigentlich traurig dass ich
überhaupt deutsche sagen muss also von
unseren freunden aus
der wohnung raus gezählt wurden die
haben gesagt wir gehen nicht ohne euch
hier raus weil heute dass das das wird
noch in mord und totschlag enden
und genau das haben mir dann meine
eltern auch so passiert und wir haben
natürlich sind immer noch befreundet mit
mit der familie und sie werden auch über
die zeit danach schon kurz gesprochen
sie hatten gesagt die neunziger jahre
die waren tatsächlich schon noch sehr
geprägt von einem ganz klaren ja offenen
teilweise auch sichtbaren rassismus ja
gut auch gesagt man konnte das in jagd
an der kleidung optisch also auch sehen
wie hat sich das weiter entwickelt in
den nullerjahren und auch danach sagen
wird man den letzten 20 jahren
ich bin ja ich bin der meinung dass man
dieses gedankengut erkennt man jetzt
heutzutage nicht sofort ich weiß nicht
ob es
massentauglich geworden ist oder ob es
sich einfach in die breite gesellschaft
eingeschlichen hat das ganz normal ja
regelmäßig
anzug und schlipsträger dass die halt
auch neonazis sein können ohne ja dass
man es sofort den leuten an sieht ja
sitzen auch welche im parlament
heutzutage
termindruck vielen dank dass sie noch
mal für uns zeit hatten heute und wir
hören jetzt nämlich rein in die rede des
bundespräsidenten
dankbar dass wir zu dieser
gemeinsamen denkt gedenkveranstaltung
zusammenkommen können und ich freue mich
ganz besonders
dass heute menschen wie sie die welt
innen und sie die berichte hier mit uns
zu diesem gedenken zusammenkommen
menschen meine damen und herren die in
jener nacht vom 24
auf den 25
august 1992
am sonnenblumenhaus
eingeschlossen war wir alle erinnern uns
an die bilder der flammen flammen die
aus den fenstern schlugen auf grausame
art bejubelt von tausenden jungen
menschen davor
gewissen darum
aber
ihre todesangst ihr gefühl des
verlassenseins in jeden stunden
das können wir also nur erahnen
hinter ihnen lagen zu diesem zeitpunkt
bereits zwei nächte der furcht nächte in
denen steine in die wohnungen geflogen
waren
geworfen von zumeist jungen männern aus
der hasserfüllten menge vor dem haus
polizisten
viel zu wenige viel zu schlecht
ausgerüstet hatten die menschen im haus
hatten sie nicht beschützen können
dutzende beamte
wurden im einsatz selbst verletzt
ich versuche mir vorzustellen wie es
gewesen sein jahrelang hatten die
ehemaligen vietnamesische
vertragsarbeiter hirn lichtenhagen
ganz friedlich mit ihren nachbarn
gewohnt und wie alle lichtenegger
konnten auch sie seit monaten die
menschen sehen die auf der suche nach
asyl zur völlig überfüllten zentralen
aufnahmestelle
nebenan kamen
im selben haus nur einen aufgang weiter
sie sahen die menschen vor dem haus
campieren
viele von ihnen sind die und roma
menschen die nichts hatten
und hier auf alles hofften
die lage war desolat viel zu wenig
geschehen sie zu verbessern und wie
jeder in lichtenhagen so spürten auch
sie die spannung
die dann in jenen nächten in roher
gewalt und hass mündete am 24 august
brachten busse die asylbewerber aus dem
wohngebiet dann
am nachmittag sammelten sich erneut
menschen vor dem sonnenblumenhaus junge
leute schüler nachbarn dazu
rechtsextremisten die die situation für
sich nutzen und
fernsehteams wandern wie auf einem
sportfest habe es ausgesehen so
beschrieben sie es hätte ihn als die
scheinwerfer
sich auf das haus richtet die
ausschreitungen und gingen weiter und
wir
wir waren drinnen in der falle so haben
sie es hätten später erzielt mehr als
120 menschen waren eingeschlossen im
haus männer frauen kinder ein
journalistenteam der
ausländerbeauftragte der stadt
helferinnen von draußen wurden
molotow-cocktails geworfen und immer
wenn wieder ein feuer loderte
jubelten die versammelten es waren
tausende die zuschauten
gruiten und klatschten die polizei war
zu schwach aufgestellt
konnte dem was da geschah nichts
entscheidendes entgegensetzen die
feuerwehr
konnte nicht löschen erst sehr viel
später angreifer drangen in das haus ein
mit stöcken bewaffnet
der menschenfeindliche hass war mitten
in der gesellschaft angekommen
es müsse nun endlich furchtbare stunden
gewesen sein stunden in denen sie alle
in diesem haus todesangst verspüren
mussten nur durch eigene kraft
durch mut und
am ende glück sind sie der katastrophe
entgangen konnten sich die
eingeschlossenen menschen selbst retten
erst aufs dach
am ende über einen anderen aufgang in
busse in eine turnhalle aber
die todesangst
die nahmen sie mit
und die angreifer
sie haben angegriffen weil sie sich aus
geredet hatten es mit menschen zu tun
sagen
warum erzähle ich das heute hier so
detailreich viele von ihnen waren
vermutlich dabei sie haben diese nacht
erlebt oder sie haben sie wie sie beide
überlebt die erinnerungen daran haben
sie seither
durch ihr leben begleitet viele andere
die nicht dabei waren auch ich erinnern
sich mit einem dumpfen schrecken an die
bilder jener tage das bild vom
sonnenblumenhaus
hat sich sozusagen als symbol in die
erinnerung unseres landes eingebrannt
rostock lichtenhagen 1992 das waren die
schlimmsten rassistischen übergriffe in
deutschland bis dahin es folgten weitere
hasserfüllte
menschenfeindliche verbrechen es waren
finsteres stunden für unser land wenn
wir über diese nächte sprechen kommen
wir schnell an den punkt an dem jemand
sagt
was hier passiert ist war unvorstellbar
sagt sich leicht
das ist als gefühl höchst
nachvollziehbar
aber es ist falsch
wir haben aus den dunkelsten kapiteln
unserer deutschen geschichte gelernt die
idee von der unvorstellbar kyte ist
ein verhängnisvoller denkfehler
unvorstellbar kyte ist eine
vielleicht schutz formuliert und um sich
nicht weiter intensiver befassen zu
müssen mit dem was gerade geschieht oder
wie es geschehen konnte was geschehen
ist
wir dürfen uns nicht in der behauptung
von unvorstellbar kite verstecken die
entscheidende frage ist doch
wie konnte es passieren
diese frage darf nicht in der luft
hängen bleiben sie zu beantworten
bedeutet präzise zu benennen was war es
bedeutet ursachen zu finden und
verantwortung zu übernehmen
ich weiß es gibt in rostock lichtenhagen
nicht wenige die sich wünschen dass man
die dinge ruhen lassen umso froher
dann umso dankbarer bin ich den vielen
die sich mittlerweile seit jahrzehnten
und in den ersten jahren noch das weiß
ich gegen einige widerstände
für die aufarbeitung und erinnerung
engagieren ich konnte mir heute bei
meinen besuchen lichtenhagen einen
eindruck davon verschaffen
mit jedem jahrestag in lichtenhagen
steigt bei einigen auch die sorge
dass die stadt ist der ganze osten immer
aufs neue stigmatisiert würde und ich
weiß sie alle haben ihre erfahrung damit
gemacht aber ich sage es ganz deutlich
der kern dieser frage ist nicht die
nach austria ließ er kern es die
erkenntnis wozu eine gesellschaft im
schlimmsten fall in der lage ist und wie
sie sich im besten fall dagegen wappnen
kann dass es nicht wieder geschieht
die ausschreitungen von rostock
lichtenhagen waren eine katastrophe mit
ansage
diese katastrophe passierte auch mit
blick auf die gesamte bundesrepublik
eben nicht aus dem nichts die
ausschreitung dieser tage gediehn auf
dem boden einer bis dahin schon
teilweise
hasserfüllt geführten debatte staat
hätte gewarnt sein müssen schon am 25
november 1990
hetzen und logen neonazis in eberswalde
den jungen angolanischen
vertragsarbeiter motto antonio zu tode
und
einem jahr vor rostock im september 1991
hatte ein mob vietnamesische
vertragsarbeiter in hoyerswerda
attackiert flüchtlingswohnheim
wurden angegriffen anwohner
applaudierten die angegriffenen mussten
auch dort
mit bussen evakuiert werden
32 menschen dort verletzt
die ausschaltung von rostock waren also
vorstellbar
und sie waren vielleicht vermeidbar
der staat hatte die menschen an
verschiedenen stellen allein gelassen
alleingelassen waren schon wochen zuvor
die asylsuchenden mit kind und kegel vor
dem haus campierten alleingelassen waren
in jenen wochen auch die anwohner
ihre klagen über die unübersehbaren
unter unhaltbaren zustände vor der
zentralen aufnahmestelle
wurden nicht gehört
ihre frage wie man die situation
verbessern würde
wurde nicht beantwortet
all das ist umso unverzeihlicher weil
zeitgleich alle auf die situation schaut
man konnte sehen was passiert die
zeitungen berichteten schon tage vorher
von anonymen drohungen von gesprächen
mit anwohnern von einer heißen nacht in
der ich zitiere für ordnung gesorgt
werden solle die roma werden auf
geklatscht hieß es da und noch etwas
wurde angekündigt die leute wurden
werden aus den fenstern schauen und
beifallklatschen
und dann passierte was passierte
allein gelassen waren in jener nacht
aber vor allem die rund 120 menschen im
haus nummer 18 nummer 19 es sind setzt
mich wenn ich höre dass diese menschen
den rat bekamen
die vorhänge zuzuziehen
damit man sie nicht entdeckt
es war also klar dass zu diesem
zeitpunkt niemand den schutz der
verbliebenen menschen
als wirklich oberste priorität begriff
der rechtsstaat der die pflicht hatte
sie zu beschützen
hat sie allein gelassen und so waren sie
einer entfesselten menge von menschen
ausgesetzt von denen viele in den jahren
zuvor
ihre nachbarn ran
was in rostock geschah
ist eine schande für unser land und für
diese schande trägt die politik große
mitverantwortung
man darf die ereignisse von rostock
nicht singulär
und auch nicht losgelöst von der damals
aktuellen politischen diskussion
betrachten die nächte von lichtenhagen
waren
ein furchtbarer auswuchs in einer ganzen
welle von menschenfeindlichen
ausschreitungen und von anschlägen auf
migranten bei denen viele menschen
getötet wurden
das sonnenblumenhaus hat sich auch
deshalb in unser kollektives gedächtnis
eingebrannt
weil es dort die fernsehbilder gab weil
man über tage praktisch in echtzeit dem
schrecken beiwohnte
viele der bundesweit
2277 angriffe auf migranten welche die
sicherheitsbehörden allein 1992 zählten
sind unter einer schicht des vergessens
begraben aber auch die sind passiert
in lichtenhagen gab es wie durch ein
wunder keine toten
nach lichtenhagen
geschahen die mordanschläge von mölln
von hengste von solingen von lübeck in
neuen gab es drei todesopfer in solingen
wurden fünf angehörige der familie genc
ermordet in lübeck kamen bei einem
brandanschlag auf ein asylbewerberheim
zehn menschen zu tode
eine spur rechter gewalt zog sich durch
deutschland
den boden für diese welle der von
rechtsextremisten befeuerten gewalt
bereitete auch die politisch aufgeheizte
debatte rechtsradikale parteien lagen im
aufwind die rhetorik auch der parteien
im demokratischen spektrum war
anfang der 90er jahre ressentiments
geladen auf klare vorurteile munde
ausschreitungen
wartete man vergebens
im land selbst waren es dann
glücklicherweise wie bürgerinnen und
bürger die eine antwort auf die
ausschreitungen fanden sie kamen dann
danach zu zehntausenden nach rostock um
die erschrecken ihre erschütterung
ihre solidarität zu zeigen
zu hunderttausenden versammelten sie
sich im winter 1992 überall in unserem
land zu lichterketten und diese
bürgerinnen und bürger zeigten was
wichtig ist
zusammenhalt
friedfertigkeit
gemeinschaft auch viele rostocker haben
sich gefragt
was die antwort auf jene nächte
eigentlich sein kann sie hatten haben
später davon berichtet wie sie sich
gemeinsam gedanken darüber machen wie
sie nach diesen tagen weiter in rostock
leben können in diesen tagen so haben
sie gesagt entstand die idee den verein
hier in hong zu gründen ihre antwort auf
den hass
war das miteinander für ihre
beharrlichkeit
und ihre zuversicht wenn ich wirklich
voller bewunderung und respekt
[Applaus]
aber ihnen allen wie sie in diesem haus
überlebt haben ist es zuallererst zu
verdanken sein zusammenleben weiter
möglich ist wir sind ihnen dankbar für
diese ungeheure kraft die sie
aufgebraucht heute könnte ich mir auch
den buddhistischen tempel der
vietnamesischen gemeinde ansehen welche
einen wunderschönen friedlichen ort der
interkulturellen begegnung haben sie
inzwischen ihren lichtenhagen geschaffen
und ich weiß auch die stadt rostock und
die bürgerschaft haben enorme
anstrengungen unternommen um die
ereignisse aufzuklären
an sie zu erinnern und sich gegen eine
wiederholung des schreckens zu warten es
ist auch an einem solchen tag wie heute
wichtig deutlich zu machen die nächte
von lichtenhagen zu gedenken bedeutet
nicht die wunderbare vielfältige
hansestadt rostock auf diese ereignisse
reduzieren zu wollen im gegenteil es
bedeutet die eigene geschichte ernst zu
nehmen aus ihr zu lernen und dann
gemeinsame zukunft zu arbeiten
das stadtteil- und begegnungszentrum
dass er 1993 errichtet wurde um
jugendlichen jungen erwachsenen eine
anlaufpunkt zu bieten ist zu einem
wichtigen zentrum
für alle lichtenegger geworden
inzwischen hat der stadtteil eine
kredits managerin ist zum fördergebiet
des bundes und landes programm soziale
stadt geworden und bei meinem besuch
vorhin im spz haben mir schülerinnen und
schüler der benachbarten hundertwasser
gesamtschule von ihrem alltag aber auch
von ihren erwartungen an die politik
gerät berichtet sind in dem alter
in dem einige jener jugendlichen vor dem
sonnenblumenhaus damals waren aber heute
haben sie einen gemeinsamen ort
und zusammenhalt
gemeinsamkeit
respekt alte es braucht immer einen
gemeinsamen ort
meine damen und herren die nächte von
rostock lichtenhagen sind nicht
vergessen
auch die gewalt von damals jene spur
rechten terrors es leider immer noch da
sie zieht sich in wellen durchs land wir
sahen sie in der furchtbaren terrorserie
des sogenannten nationalsozialistischen
untergrundes wie sahen sie 2015 inhalten
und freitag sie zieht sich durch kassel
halle und hanau
viel zu lange haben wir diese spur nicht
ernst genug genommen dabei hätten wir
schon aus rostock lichtenhagen die
richtigen lehren ziehen müssen
lehren die bis heute aktuell sind und
nur drei von ihnen will ich erfüllen wir
wissen eigentlich alle worte können
waffen seien mit worten kann man das
gewaltpotenzial einer gesellschaft
aktivieren man kann es
instrumentalisieren damals war die
politische debatte so dass sie die
gewalt befeuerte wir haben auch meine
damen und herren in jüngerer zeit
schmerzlich erlebt wie aus worten taten
werden der tödliche terroranschlag gegen
den kommunalpolitiker walter lübke
erinnert uns an die mörderische
radikalisierung sword kraft der worte
die häme die sich nach seinem tod in
soziale netzwerke ergoss erinnert uns
daran wie kurz der weg der
entmenschlichung des gegenübers gerade
im digitalen raum sanken es gilt also
verbal abzurüsten und ich beobachte mit
sorge
wie sich die grenze zwischen dem
sagbaren
und dem unsäglichen verschiebt
dies zu verhindern
muss bei aller notwendigkeit der
kontroverse dies zu verhindern die
oberste pflicht derer die sich zu wort
melden politiker medien
publizisten sind die allesamt in einer
ganz besonderen verantwortung und für
uns alle gilt es den mechanismen der
sozialen medien zu widerstehen welche
ausgerechnet das widerlichste verbale
schwert mit größte reichweite belohnt
die zweite lehre betrifft jeden von uns
ganz direkt und sie betrifft auch
diejenigen in politischer verantwortung
der staat muss jederzeit alles ihr
mögliche tun jeden einzelnen bürger in
der offenen gesellschaft
gegen angriffe zu schützen ein staat der
zu lange zuschaut oder unter reagiert
schützt die gefährdeten nicht
ausreichend vor den gefahren
ein staat der im entscheidenden moment
abwesend ist
nimmt furchtbare folgenden kauf die
notwendigkeit unsere demokratie wehrhaft
zu machen ist eine zentrale erkenntnis
aus unserer geschichte auch unsere
jüngeren und jüngsten geschichte
das dürfen wir nicht vergessen
für das friedliche zusammenleben
allerdings kommt es auch auf jeden
einzelnen an in rostock lichtenhagen
inheidener bei den jüngsten
ausschreitungen während des protestes in
der pandemie galt es war
jederzeit möglich nein zu sagen
es war möglich nicht zu applaudieren als
ein brandsatz durchs fenster flog es war
möglich nicht in den sprechchor
einzufallen der drei nächte lang ertönte
es war nicht nur möglich der verzicht
auf hetze und gewalt
ist in einer offenen gesellschaft
erste bürgerpflicht
drittens und letztens
die dritte lehre aus lichtenhagen ist
für uns heute besonders wichtig wenn
eine gesellschaft unter
veränderungsdruck steht dann ist der weg
der radikalisierung
noch kürzer weil er vermeintlich
einfache lösungen anbietet ich würde
sagen vorgaukelt die einfachste aller
lösungen ist die suche nach einem
vermeintlich schuldigen die
konfrontation mit einer ungewissen
zukunft scheint diesen reflex
zu bestärken die suche nach dem glied in
der gesellschaft das zum sündenbock wird
oft reicht dafür nur verschiedenheit aus
ihre dann feindschaft konstruiert und
das ist der
zerstörerische reflex für eine offene
gesellschaft für uns heißt es das risiko
dass die spur dass die spur der gewalt
nicht endet ist hoch gerade jetzt in
einer zeit die uns herausfordert wie
keines der letzten jahrzehnte einer zeit
die uns viel abverlangt in der gewohntes
in frage steht und einschränkungen
drohen das risiko opfer zu werden von
kollektiver wut hetze und gewalt tragen
aber nicht alle in gleicher weise das
gilt für lichtenhagen für möllen für
halle für hanau und aus dieser
erkenntnis
folgt eine gesellschaftliche pflicht es
gilt für uns alle denjenigen schutz zu
bieten die potenzielle opfer sind es
gilt für uns alle wachsam zu sein
für h feine risse im zusammenleben
wehrhaft gegen die feinde dieser
gesellschaft und
friedfertig im umgang miteinander
vor allem aber solidarisch mit den
bedrohten wir dürfen sie
niemals im stich lassen das ist die
lehre aus lichtenhagen vielen dank
[Applaus]
das war die rede des bundespräsidenten
frank walter
steinmeier heute 30 jahre zum gedenken
nach den rassistischen anschlägen in
rostock lichtenhagen
kurz zusammengefasst was wir gehört
haben von ihm frank walter steinmeier
sprach davon dass ist immer hieß so was
er unvorstellbar was passiert und die
idee der unvorstellbar kite das sei ein
denkfehler das sagte er nicht das sei
eine behauptung hinter der man sich
nicht verstecken dürfe hinter dieser
unvorstellbar kite und
erfordert vor allem auch verantwortung
zu übernehmen er dankte vor allem auch
all jenen die das damals durchgemacht
haben dass ein zusammenleben hier in
deutschland weiter möglich ist und er
sprach von drei lehrern die erste worte
können waffen seien so sagte der
bundespräsident die zweite der staat
müsse jederzeit alles tun um jede und
jeden einzelnen gegen angriffe zu
schützen und die dritte lehre die er aus
rostock lichtenhagen zieht wenn die
gesellschaft unter veränderungsdruck
steht so sagte er ist der weg der
radikalisierung noch kürzer weil er
einfache lösungen anbietet er forderte
von uns allen solidarisch mit bedrohten
zu sein wir dürfen sie niemals im stich
lassen und wir wollen jetzt im zweiten
teil unserer sendung sprechen mit der
politologin und autorin im emilia ich
bin sehr froh dass sie heute auch bei
uns zu gast ist denn wir können auch
gemeinsam vor allem auch über die
situation
wie stehen wir da rassismus heute in
deutschland sprechen schönen guten abend
gut' vielen dank frau der
bundespräsident hat das in seiner rede
auch angesprochen wir alle wissen es
rassistische anschläge auf menschen die
gab es auch nach rostock lichtenhagen
noch die gab es auch in der jüngsten
vergangenheit noch wir erinnern uns an
hanau in heidenau anmelden das ist schon
länger her also so vieles was danach
noch passiert ist sehen sie die gefahr
für rassistische übergriffe
2022 immer noch genauso hoch wie in all
den letzten jahren und jahrzehnten
also ja auf jeden fall ich würde nicht
sagen dass das risiko kleiner geworden
er ist ganz im gegenteil das kann sich
noch erhöhen anhand der kritischen
politischen situation anhand der krise
in so vielen bereichen also das heißt
dass diesen hassen diese
ich glaube diese übergriffe der
rassismus der hier in der deutschen
gesellschaft steckt bleibt hier und es
muss auch dezidiert eingegangen werden
aber dass ich jetzt nicht etwas dass von
heute auf morgen verschwindet deshalb
finde ich ein historischer umgang auch
mit diesen anschlägen sehr sehr wichtig
und zu zeigen dass es neben sei der show
den roma und sinti auch kein also nicht
ein groß genug bruch gab seit dieser
zeit das heißt es die ideologie die
dahinter steckt ist noch nach vorhanden
leider und das hieß nach hanau immer ein
bisschen man spüre einen leichten
gesellschaftlichen wandel zumindest in
der aufarbeitung mit einem größeren
blick auf die opfer nehmen sie das
genauso wahr oder sagen sie danach hat
sich auch nicht wirklich was getan
doch das hat sich was getan ich würde
sagen dass die aufarbeitung von hanau
ich glaube die solidarität die auch von
vielen menschen die selbst betroffen
sind von rassismus von rassistischer
gewalt
hat sich auch gezeigt es gab glaube ich
lehre die aufgezogen wurden von der
vergangenheit aber und die art und weise
wie diese anschläge passiert sind wie
diese gewalt geschehen ist und die
mangelnde bereitschaft eben von der
polizei auch früh genug
solche gewalt zu erkennen und ernst zu
nehmen hat sich leider nicht verändert
und in dieser hinsicht finde ich auch
wichtig dass wir jetzt nicht mehr über
menschen ähnliche gewalt sprechen
sondern über rassismus oder rassistische
gewalt weil es ist kein keine
menschenfeindlichkeit die jetzt menschen
pauschal betreffen sondern es hat der
grund dafür ist rassismus und dieser
rassismus dieser system muss
unterstrichen werden es ist wichtig dass
wir das als solche benennen vor allem
hier in deutschland und vor allem äußert
sich rassismus nicht nur in solchen
schrecklichen anschlägen sondern eben
auch im kleineren im alltag dinge die
ich als weißer mensch noch nie erfahren
habe wie können weiße denn die realität
von people of colour da mehr sehen sie
beschäftigen sich intensiv mit diesem
thema
ja ich würde sagen das ist eine empathie
lücke gibt gegenüber
den erfahrungen die nicht weiße menschen
machen nicht nur hier in deutschland
sondern im allgemeinen weil die
lebensperspektiven die interessen die
empfindlichkeiten von und die
verletzbarkeit die verwundbarkeit von
bibelausgaben schwarze menschen werden
werden verharmlost und nicht wirklich
ernst genommen deshalb das weiße
menschen tun können ist überhaupt zu
hören und auch
nicht erst mal in der defensive haltung
kommen dann ich bin das nicht ich bin
nicht rassistisch das meinte ich nicht
so sondern einfach zu gehören und merken
ja es gibt in unserer gesellschaft an
rassismus problem auf allen ebenen der
gesellschaft sowohl auf der
individuellen ebene aber als auch der
institutionellen ebene in der empfehlung
der macht gibt es auch viel gewalt die
mir auch persönlich viel angst macht
also nicht zuletzt in der polizei in der
bundeswehr wo ebenso diese die diese
also diese ideologien auch mehrmals
entlarvt wurden aufgezeigt wurden und
deshalb finde ich wichtig dass hier die
stimmen von den menschen die betroffen
sind auch erstmal zuhören ohne sie zu in
frage zu stellen oder ohne sie zu
oder ohne ohne defensive haltung erst
mal
ich möchte auch unsere community ein
bisschen mit einbinden hier in unser
gespräch ich lese vor allem auch viele
kommentare möchte davon ein paar
aufgreifen da schreibt halligalli bei
youtube hoffentlich haben wir heute so
viel mut und empathie in der
gesellschaft dass man sich dem rechten
gewalt mob entgegenstellt sollte sowas
wie in rostock noch mal passieren und
rom ergänzt bei youtube die mitläufer
denken genauso wer dazu schaut
zugeschaut hat ohne einzugreifen macht
sich der gesinnung gemein das sind jetzt
nur zwei stimmen mal raus gegriffen aus
unserem stream wie sie hatten das eben
angesprochen es gibt also auch gewalt im
alltag in institutionen die ihnen angst
macht wo wird da immer noch zu wenig
hingeschaut ihrer meinung nach
ich würde sagen in den filmen der macht
die über waffen verfügen die über eben
staatliche gewalt verfügen was heißt
jetzt ich habe von ein gutes werk
gesprochen und von der polizei ich rede
auch natürlich in dem im justizsektor
das heißt wie wie tief ist unser justiz
in deutschland in rassistischen muster
verankert was kann da auch gemacht
werden die medien also ich würde sagen
alle gesellschaftlichen sphären wo sich
die macht auch ausdrückt sollten unter
die lupe genommen werden es sollte ein
pc dieser kampf gegen rassismus geben
auf allen diesen ebenen und das was auch
gesagt wird über rechte gewalt ich
glaube das problem ist dass viele
menschen in deutschland glauben
sicher oder geschützt zu sein von
rechter gewalt wenn sie in weiß sind
aber rechter gewalt betrifft auch viele
andere menschen die auch nicht nur
people of colour sind das wäre ja
vielleicht auch noch mal sehen in den
netten in dem gespräch aber das ist auch
eine ich glaube eine illusion eine
gefährliche illusion zu glauben dass
wenn man eine weiße person in
deutschland ist dann hat man nicht von
den neonazis zu fürchten das stimmt
nicht sie haben es angesprochen sie
haben das center for international
justice gegründet was ich mit genau den
verschiedenen sage ich jetzt mal lagen
von diskriminierung auch beschäftigt
vielleicht mal ganz kurz für alle die
sich damit noch nicht so intensiv
auseinandergesetzt haben was ist
internationalität
intersexualität ist eine theorie die aus
den usa stammt aus schwarzen frauen und
insbesondere eine schwarze juristin land
china die trendshow und diese theorie
analysiert die
verschränkung von unterschiedlichen
diskriminierungs formen und
unterschiedlichen unterdrückung systemen
das heißt es wird nicht nur auf die
achse hautfarbe oder die achse des
schlecht oder die achse soziale klasse
geschaut sondern wirklich an der
wechselwirkung und verschränkung von
diesen unterschiedlichen
identitätsmerkmal und diskriminierungs
formen
und wo oder warum glauben sie auch dass
es so wichtig ist sich gerade in
deutschland intersexualität
auseinanderzusetzen
also zum beispiel wenn wir jetzt über
rassismus sprechen und über rassistische
gewalt es macht einen unterschied ob man
es zum beispiel eine muslimische frau
mit kopftuch ist oder ein mutiger mann
ohne kopftuch in diesem fall wo wir
sehen dass die meiste gewalt auf der
straße physische gewalt
wird eben von frauen muss sie nicht mit
frauen mit kopftuch auch erlebt und das
heißt dass diese spezifizität müssen
auch erkannt werden wenn wir jetzt über
racial profiling das heißt ethnisches
profi links von der polizei durch die
polizei spielt auch hier die soziale
klasse eine wichtige rolle was heißt es
ist nicht eher sind nicht nur menschen
also die nicht weil sind also schwarze
menschen die paarlauf kader muss ich
mich für menschen arabischer menschen
sondern auch diejenigen die aus den
benachteiligten sozialen milieus kommen
oder auch die einen
migrationshintergrund oder eine
migrationserfahrung auch aufweisen
weshalb diese unterschiedlichen
erfahrungen spielen auch eine rolle in
ihrer gesamtheit und das muss auf jeden
fall darauf geschaut werden das sind
nicht es gibt keine gruppe die homogen
ist und mit eine einzige erfahrung zum
beispiel hier so people of colour in
deutschland report of color ist mir
jetzt sehr diverse gruppe die auch
sowohl menschen mit behinderung menschen
die reichen und die armen sind andere
die studiert haben andere nicht es gibt
auch viele menschen aus der lgbt
community die auch bibel of color sind
es gibt frauen und männer trans menschen
also das ist deshalb sehr wichtig nicht
nur auf einer achse der diskriminierung
zu schauen sind vielleicht auch themen
mit denen sich manche noch nicht so
intensiv auseinandergesetzt haben ich
lese dass so ein bisschen hier auch bei
uns im stream nämlich raus bei youtube
ein kommentar in der schule geht es
immer nur über die zeit von 1930 bis
1945 sehr abstrakt als hätte man mit dem
jetzt nichts zu tun und dann schließt
sich da auch eine frage direkt an sie an
das komme man kurz nach oben und zwar
fragte sich hier dass sie eine frage an
sie frau rohr wie viel wird in schulen
getan um über rassismus aufzuklären
meiner erfahrung nach nämlich wenig
obwohl es ja da anfangen sollte also ja
viel zu wenig spiele nicht in
deutschland so schnell gegangen ich kann
genau das gleiche über frankreich sagen
die aufarbeitung der vergangenheit der
kolonial kolonialen vergangenheit sowohl
in frankreich als auch in deutschland
weil deutschland war auch ein
kolonialstadt wird nicht oder wirklich
nicht genug verarbeitet und auch die
aufarbeitung der shoah die aufarbeitung
des genozids ist längst also es gibt da
auch luft nach oben nämlich die
aufarbeitung des koran denn das genozid
gegenüber den roma und sinti sich hier
in deutschland es wird viel zu wenig
getan darüber und ich glaube da müssten
wir auch noch viel tun um über die
kontinuitäten über die anknüpfung
inzwischen der vergangenheit und der
gegenwart auch mehr zu sprechen es gab
keinen bruch ein klares und
naja ein klares bruch zwischen nach 1945
gab es jetzt nicht in diesem sinne na
klar es hat sich viel getan und das also
diese fortschritte müssten auch auf
jeden fall gefeiert werden aber es gibt
noch viel dass deutschland gemacht
machen kann und jetzt über eine eine
eine post rassistische gesellschaft zu
sprechen jeder ist bis vor kurzem auch
gemacht wurde ist höchst problematischen
gewiss nicht auch dagegen kämpfen weil
rassismus in deutschland ist noch eine
realität die millionen von menschen
betrifft genau sie haben uns gesagt eine
betrifft sie haben vor allem auch gesagt
auch weiße menschen sollen sich da bloß
nicht in sicherheit wiegen dass sie
nicht von diskriminierung betroffen sind
und sie haben ja auch schon einen ganz
wichtigen punkt gesagt sie haben gesagt
zu hören das ist das erste was aber
weiße menschen tun können um natürlich
auch die perspektive von nicht weißen
menschen besser verstehen zu koennen
trotzdem möchte ich nochmal aufgreifen
weil es ja auch so wichtig ist eine
frage von raphael sümpelmann der bei
youtube wissen möchte was kann jeder
jeder einzelne gegen alltagsrassismus
tun
also gegen alltagsrassismus zu händeln
ist glaube ich eine dauerhafte aufgabe
ist so was nie aufhört und wir müssen
die rache verlernen die uns termiten hat
in büchern in bildern in vynen in der
wissenschaft auch weil rassismus war
sehr tiefe an kehrt in der wissenschaft
wurde produziert eben von der
wissenschaft diese garage die weiße
menschen über alle anderen menschen
stellt muss verlernt werden die tatsache
dass die menschheit in unterschiedlichen
vermeintlichen rassen aufgeteilt wurden
ist eine lüge deshalb keine biologische
grundlage und dementsprechend diese ja
sie ist auch eine lüge dennoch sie
strukturiert immer noch die neuzugänge
der menschen zu macht zu ressourcen zu
empathie und das soll sich ändern also
im alltag was man machen kann ist sehr
viel darüber lesen versuchen zu
verstehen was ist überhaupt heißt es nur
dass ich mehr als eine haltung mehr als
eine meinung rassismus ist ein system
also es gibt mittlerweile sehr viele
ressourcen die uns
auch beibringen können woher das kommt
also ich hab selber auch ein buch
darüber geschrieben mein wunsch war ihm
rassismus und unterdrückung greifbarer
zu machen für die menschen die nicht
unbedingt damit betroffene ziehen von
für den menschen die damit betroffen
sind genau es gibt sehr viel wissen
was ich dem menschen einen eigenen
können um dagegen zu kämpfen
genau in diesem buch geht es auch um
verschiedene formen von unterdrückung
das haben sie dort sehr eindrücklich
beschrieben wie könnte denn so ein ende
der unterdrückung aussehen das wäre
natürlich auch noch mal ne frage hier
zum schluss unserer sendung dieser
interessant wäre also das ende der
untere kubi könnte es aussehen also das
ist ein prozess ist auch ein chaotischer
prozessen zu sagen weil es geht jetzt um
die
jahrhundertealte und also für das bad
auch mehrere tausend jahren alten
systeme die so tief in unserer
gesellschaft verankert sind das sind die
ein fundament auf bilden und deshalb wir
brauchen eine revolution auf ganz ganz
vielen ebenen also ich möchte jetzt kurz
noch mal dass pro zeigen wie marta das
ende der unterdrückung zeigt auch in der
hinsicht wie ein ende der unterdrückung
kann die nähere prozess ist ich glaube
wir sind jetzt schon unterwegs das heißt
diese veränderung passiert auf
organischer weise natürlich die politik
und die handlungen von den einzelnen
menschen sind sehr wichtig nicht aber
die summe davon ist auch wichtig die
summe davon bringt uns auch generell
weiter wenn wir jetzt schauen wo wir ihn
ja tatsächlich in 1940 waren sind wir
heute weiter als ich noch nicht wo wir
sein wollen aber diese fortschritte
haben auch dennoch stattgefunden dann
den kämpfen und das muss ich auch
wirklich unterstreichen den kämpfen
langwierigen kämpfen dann
antirassistischen aktivisten
aktivistinnen die sich mühelos und
unermüdlich und und auch gegen dem strom
auch kämpfen für eine gesellschaft ohne
sich ziemlich unterdrückung und diese
diese stimme menschen die gegen
rassismus kämpfen werden ständig auch
diskreditiert sie werden verteufelt und
den fortschritten die wir heute erleben
haben wir ihnen teilweise auch
größtenteils zu also kosten zu verdanken
sagte binias politologin autorin war
heute unser gast an dem tag 30 jahren
nach rostock lichtenhagen vielen dank
dass sie sich die zeit für uns genommen
haben vielen dank
und danke auch an eure zeit ich habe
nochmal in die kommentare geschaut das
waren viele spannende fragen dabei und
möchte jetzt zum schluss auch noch ein
kommentar vorlesen von michael rossmann
der bei facebook schrieb das war damals
schlimm man darf nicht vergessen wir
sind überall auf der welt selbst
ausländer so nennt es nur im eigenen
land nicht und damit wollen wir den
stream beenden das war auf jeden fall
sehr spannend was wir da alles mitnehmen
konnten und deswegen sage ich danke an
euren input und bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss
[Musik]